here is your very first look at Hogwarts
Legacy running on a Nintendo switch
these are official screenshots you can
find for yourself right now on the
switch store page for Hogwarts Legacy
now I know switch owners have been
waiting a long time for this game and as
we inch closer to launch there are a few
important details you need to know if
you're planning to pick up the game for
the switch I'm happy to say this finally
confirms we are not looking at a cloud
version here this is a game that
Avalanche has worked incredibly hard on
to get it running natively on the switch
Hardware you're looking at just under 7
GB for the install size so go ahead and
make sure you have enough room for when
the game releases and what is now less
than 1 month away on November 14th
additionally there are two different
versions of the game and you should read
the details about each one carefully you
have your standard version of the game
that's priced at $59.99 but there's also
a deluxe version for $10 more at $69.99
it's been quite some time since they
revealed the perks for these versions so
we'll go over those here in a bit but
the most important thing to know is that
if you were at all interested in the
items we're about to talk about you
actually Sav $10 by going for the deluxe
version instead of buying what's
included separately which is an option
for those who change their mind later so
what's included here in the 6999 digital
deluxe version of Hogwarts Legacy of
course you get the base game but in
addition to that you'll get the dark
arts cosmetic pack this includes the
Thal Mount access to the dark arts
battle arena the dark arts cosmetic set
and the dark arts Garrison hat
everything you see me wearing here as
well as the thestral mount the only way
to obtain them is through the dark arts
pack as for that dark arts battle arena
there are two other Arenas included in
the game that everyone will have access
to if you want to spam the unforgivables
like Bellatrix though then you'll need
that dark arts battle arena an important
note here though this does not mean that
you lose out on the unforgivable curses
without this pack there were a lot of
people confused about this leading up to
the game's launch on current genin and
it's just not the case to be clear the
base version of Hogwarts Legacy does
include the unforgivable curses which
you have the option of learning within
the story so let's say you do purchase
that base version of the game and then
later you change your mind about the
dark arts pack it is is available as an
add-on purchase on the Nintendo eShop
however it's priced at $19.99 so you
actually end up paying $10 more if you
end up buying later I should also point
out they do occasionally run sales on
other platforms even on the dark arts
pack so for example at the time of this
recording it's priced at $13.99 on the
PlayStation Store even there though it
would have been slightly cheaper just
buying the deluxe version of the game to
begin with now which version you pick up
is all totally up to you I want to be
very clear you do not lose out on any
core mechanics or any core features in
the game if you go with that Standard
Version you can fully enjoy Hogwarts
Legacy without that pack really it's
just for people who really want that
dark art set or really like the thestral
mount that's what you're looking at
getting here now anyone who pre-orders
the game regardless of which version you
choose you will get access to the Onyx
hippogriff Mount you unlock a standard
hippogriff simply by playing the game
but this pre-order bonus gives you
another variation of the iconic
Wizarding World creature I do want to
point out this is not something you
unlock right away so don't be alarmed
when you start the game and you're not
going to have access to it just yet in
fact you have to play several hours into
the game before you unlock the mounts at
all now getting these official
screenshots and finally seeing Hogwarts
Legacy on the switch it's awesome to see
especially for those who have been
holding out all this time to play the
game within the images we can certainly
see the sacrifices that have been made
to get this running on the switch
Hardware you can compare what we see
here to what we already have on the
current gen platforms of course the
major benefit of the switch though is
that you can take the game on the go and
play on the small screen so while we now
have some idea of what the game will
look like on the switch we haven't seen
it in motion yet how will it actually
perform in terms of the frame rate
considering the concessions we can see
Avalanche has made and the level of
graphical Fidelity and the fact that the
Nintendo switch screen is a resolution
of 720p I would expect a solid 30fps
performance here I do not expect to see
this running at 60 frames per second on
the switch one important thing to keep
in mind is that Avalanche does have
prior experience working on the switch
Hardware as their most recent game
before Hogwarts Legacy Cars 3 driven to
win was actually released on the switch
in 2017 now if you are one of those
people getting ready to play for the
first time on the Nintendo switch then I
have some important spoiler-free tips
tips that I wish I knew before I started
playing the game these are going to save
you a lot of time make sure that you're
getting the most out of your time with
Hogwarts Legacy I'll link to that video
here on the left side of your screen now
as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again
soon